This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman, Angel Geratana, Jeremy Colhane, Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast.
在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，附赠Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动支付优惠。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接即一切。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman、Angel Geratana、Jeremy Colhane、Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。
The improvised character comedy podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween.
这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都会有一组新的艺术家讨论他们的创作。加入我们，听听欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的座谈会。我们有时也会搞点万圣节活动。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他就在麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。
Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with Survivors, who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是Elizabeth Smart，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会与那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。这些故事讲述了如何才能活着走出来。
Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks pride and prejudice and love island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture, with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Elizabeth Smart的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Pro Society》是一档每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合那些认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、BookTok创作者以及大量深思熟虑的观点一起，连接书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴。
Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to pro-society on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So by age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening. happening inside your kids' brain, the group chats and their friendships, and what you can do about it. Your child is not doing this on purpose.
是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。所以到了11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩的疗法》。我们花时间在“幸存初中”系列中深入探讨孩子们大脑中正在发生的事情、群聊和友谊，以及你能为此做些什么。你的孩子不是故意这样做的。
That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemis Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s and beyond at this stage and beyond. Today we are talking about something that I think most of us have
这就是我们从研究这一领域的心理学家和精神病学家那里汲取的观点。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《黑人女孩的疗法》。大家好。我是Jemis Spike，欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们会在这个阶段及以后剖析二十岁的心理。今天我们要谈论的是我认为我们大多数人
spent a lot of time trying to get rid of, which is stress. We are living in. We are living in in a very anti-stress error. We want to regulate our nervous systems. We want to lower our cortisol. We want to have better boundaries, you know, all of which is incredibly valuable and incredibly important. Stress is a killer. Only in the last, I think, 50 years have we really started to understand the psychological impact of chronic stress and the biological impact on our DNA, our life expectancy on our relationships. All of that is very, very valid. But I think somewhere along the way, we've kind of simplified this a little bit too much, and we've lumped all stress into the bad stress category. However, stress is not just something that happens when life is
花了很多时间试图摆脱的东西，那就是压力。我们生活在一个非常反压力的时代。我们想要调节神经系统。我们想要降低皮质醇。我们想要有更好的界限，你知道，所有这些都非常有价值，非常重要。压力是杀手。我认为在过去50年里，我们才真正开始了解慢性压力的心理影响，以及对我们DNA、预期寿命和人际关系的生物学影响。所有这些都是非常、非常有效的。但我认为在某种程度上，我们把这个问题简化得太多了，把所有的压力都归入了坏压力类别。然而，压力不仅仅是发生在生活
going badly. Stress happens when we care. Some of our very best moments in life will also be the most stressful, because stress is just one of your body's most ancient, inbuilt survival mechanisms for showing us what is important and showing us what we need to pay attention to and tending to it. So today, in a world of a lot of bad stress, we are going to break down the psychology behind how you can convert this arousal into something that actually helps you. We're going to learn about the difference between good stress and bad stress, whether those categories are helpful, the role of cognitive appraisal, which is one of the most powerful things your brain can do for you, and why some of the most successful and
不顺时的事情。当我们关心某事时，压力就会发生。生活中一些最美好的时刻也会是最有压力的，因为压力只是你身体最古老的、内置的生存机制之一，用来向我们展示什么是重要的，展示我们需要注意什么并处理它。所以今天，在一个充满坏压力的世界里，我们将剖析心理学，看看你如何将这种唤醒转化为真正有帮助的东西。我们将了解好压力和坏压力之间的区别，这些类别是否有帮助，认知评估的作用——这是你大脑能为你做的最强大的事情之一，以及为什么一些最成功和
emotionally aware people, microdose stress in a way that actually may help expand their minds according to neuroscience. And in some pretty remarkable ways, there is so much brilliant research to cover that has only just come out. Some amazing papers from Stanford, some from the U.S., from the UK, from Germany. There's literally so much evidence and science to get into. So I hope you enjoy the episode. A brief reminder, though, this episode and many others, just like it now on Netflix. So before we get into it, if you want a video version of this podcast, you can go and watch it over there. But without further ado, let's get into the psychology around stress.
情绪觉知力高的人会以一种根据神经科学可能有助于扩展思维的方式“微量服用”压力。在一些非常显著的方面，有太多精彩的研究刚刚出炉。一些来自斯坦福大学、美国、英国、德国的惊人论文。真的有太多的证据和科学可以深入探讨。所以我希望你喜欢这一集。不过，简要提醒一下，这一集和许多其他类似的内容现在都在Netflix上。所以在我们开始之前，如果你想要这个播客的视频版本，你可以去那里观看。但事不宜迟，让我们进入关于压力的心理学。
So when we talk about stress, what are we actually referring to? Not to kind of give you like an Oxford dictionary definition, but basically, in short, stress is our body's, natural and normal reaction to feeling threatened or feeling under pressure. When we are stressed, our body releases a hormone that we all know called adrenaline, and that activates something called fight or flight. This hormone adrenaline usually gives us a boost to motivate us or to act quickly. That is often helpful because stress can be brought on by a huge range of things that we want to be alert to and we want to avoid, and we also hopefully want to perform better at.
那么当我们谈论压力时，我们实际上指的是什么？不是为了给你一个牛津词典式的定义，但简而言之，压力是我们身体对感到威胁或感到压力时的一种自然和正常的反应。当我们感到压力时，我们的身体会释放一种我们都知道的激素，叫做肾上腺素，它会激活所谓的“战斗或逃跑”反应。这种肾上腺素通常会给我们一种动力，激励我们或迅速采取行动。这通常是有帮助的，因为压力可能由我们想要警惕和想要避免的各种事情引起，我们也希望在这些事情上表现得更好。
So it can be everything from trying to escape a bad situation to sitting in exam, running late, having a difficult conversation. There is a whole scale of things that our body kind of uses stress for as a cure all to get us out of a situation or through a situation we want to perform well in. I think we typically see stress as a bad reaction to bad things, but what is lesser known is that there are different types of stress, different levels, some of which are beneficial to you. Let's work through those levels together.
所以它可以是任何事情，从试图逃离糟糕的情况到参加考试、迟到、进行艰难的对话。我们的身体利用压力作为一种万能药，让我们摆脱某种情况或度过我们想要表现良好的情况，这有一整套尺度。我认为我们通常把压力看作是对坏事的坏反应，但鲜为人知的是，压力有不同的类型、不同的程度，其中一些对你有益。让我们一起研究这些层次。
So firstly, we have acute stress. This is short-term stress that comes and goes quickly. It can be positive or negative. So what we call you stress, which is motivating rather than threatening. And then distress, which is, in the name, threatening and overwhelming and doesn't feel very good. so normally associated with things that bring a kind of sense of dangerous arousal, this kind of stress, acute stress, peaks very quickly. And it also subsides very quickly as well.
首先，我们有急性压力。这是短期压力，来得快去得也快。它可以是积极的，也可以是消极的。所以我们称之为“良性压力”（eustress），它是激励性的而不是威胁性的。然后是“痛苦”（distress），顾名思义，它是威胁性的、压倒性的，感觉不太好。所以通常与带来某种危险唤醒感的事情相关，这种压力，急性压力，达到峰值非常快。而且它消退得也非常快。
And that's important to remember, and that's the first level acute stress. Then we have episodic acute stress, which is where we experience acute stress regularly. This is not helpful. Even if the episodes are very, very brief, we don't want to be there very often. When you experience such a rapid onset of arousal so regularly, you basically don't ever get the time you need to return to a calm baseline. And so there is this like lingering constant state of emergency. We know that goes on to impact everything else in our life, like rest, like diet, like social connection, your emotional state. Episodic acute stress is often associated with certain professions in particular or certain kind of life circumstances.
记住这一点很重要，这是第一层：急性压力。然后我们有情境性急性压力，即我们定期经历急性压力。这没有帮助。即使这些发作非常、非常短暂，我们也不希望经常处于这种状态。当你如此频繁地经历如此快速的唤醒时，你基本上永远没有时间回到平静的基线。因此，存在一种挥之不去的持续紧急状态。我们知道这会影响我们生活中的其他一切，比如休息、饮食、社交联系、你的情绪状态。情境性急性压力通常与特定的职业或特定的生活环境有关。
but, you know, working in healthcare is a common one. A stressful relationship is another one. Stressful housing situations where, like, you just can't be fully present or use your space as you like or you don't feel safe. Even just certain periods of life where you're just kind of thrown one intense thing after another can trigger this form of stress. If this lasts for a while, as I said, there is probably not a single area of your life that will not be touched by it.
但是，你知道，在医疗保健行业工作就是一个常见的例子。一段充满压力的关系是另一个例子。充满压力的住房状况，比如你无法完全放松或无法按自己喜欢的方式使用空间，或者你感到不安全。即使只是生活中某些被接二连三地抛出强烈事件的时期，也会触发这种形式的压力。如果这种情况持续一段时间，正如我所说，你生活中可能没有哪个领域不会受到它的影响。
After this, though, we have the worst type of stress, quote unquote, worst, which is chronic stress. This is the kind of stress we consider a healthcare problem or even an illness. Chronic stress can also be professional, but it's most likely associated with something that feels unmovable in your life. So ongoing financial dread, family trauma, a chronic illness, something that is just systematic and everywhere you look. Now, these layers are important when we talk about some of the common myths that surround stress
不过，在此之后，我们有最糟糕的压力类型，所谓的“最糟糕”，即慢性压力。这是我们认为的医疗保健问题甚至疾病。慢性压力也可能是职业性的，但它最可能与你生活中感觉无法改变的事情有关。比如持续的经济恐惧、家庭创伤、慢性疾病，某种系统性的、随处可见的东西。现在，当我们谈论围绕压力的一些常见误区时，这些层次很重要
because we need to know that there are different levels in order to break down these bigger myths, one of them being that all stress is bad and that all stress is the same. We know that's not true. We're going to get to that a little bit later. But before, let's run through some other common myths about your stressed state that are really important for you to know if you want to have a good relationship with stress. The first myth is that stress is the same for everyone. Everyone is going to feel the same way about a misflight.
因为我们需要知道存在不同的层次，才能打破这些更大的误区，其中之一就是所有的压力都是坏的，所有的压力都是一样的。我们知道那不是真的。我们稍后会谈到这一点。但在那之前，让我们回顾一下关于你压力状态的其他常见误区，如果你想与压力建立良好的关系，了解这些非常重要。第一个误区是压力对每个人来说都是一样的。每个人对错过航班的感觉都是一样的。
Everybody's going to feel the same way about having a busy time at work or having a fight with a friend. This is largely inaccurate. Very inaccurate, actually. How each of us responds to stress, where we feel stress in the body, how much stress each of us can tolerate, is supremely different. Very, very different. Firstly, there is a thing known in psychology as the stress threshold. And this is basically the maximum level of physical and mental pressure that your body can handle before it stops coping.
每个人对工作繁忙或与朋友吵架的感觉都是一样的。这在很大程度上是不准确的。实际上非常不准确。我们每个人对压力的反应方式、我们在身体哪里感受到压力、我们每个人能忍受多少压力，都是极其不同的。非常、非常不同。首先，心理学中有一个概念叫做压力阈值。这基本上是你的身体在停止应对之前所能承受的身体和精神压力的最大水平。
Before it kind of is like, I really can't do anything else about this situation. For some people, you reach that threshold really, really quickly. You know, it only takes one or two things in your day or your week to be overwhelming for you to reach your threshold. For others, you know, I've encountered people whose car is broken down in the morning and then they've got to work, realize they missed a deadline in the afternoon. Then they get an alert that a bill has been unpaid and then they have dinner with their in-laws all in the same day and their stress threshold is not met. They're fine. They're easygoing still. It all depends on what the psychiatrist Dan Siegel calls your window for tolerance. Your window for tolerance
在它有点像“我真的无法再处理这种情况了”之前。对于有些人来说，你很快、很快就会达到那个阈值。你知道，你的一天或一周里只需要一两件事让你感到不知所措，你就会达到阈值。对于其他人，你知道，我遇到过一些人，他们的车早上坏了，然后他们去上班，下午意识到错过了一个截止日期。然后他们收到通知说有一笔账单没付，然后他们和姻亲一起吃晚饭，所有这些都在同一天发生，而他们的压力阈值并没有达到。他们很好。他们仍然随和。这一切都取决于精神病学家Dan Siegel所说的你的“容忍窗口”。你的容忍窗口
it's critical to remember that and how you interpret the threat capacity of a situation. So how you interpret your ability to cope and how you interpret how scary the thing is that you're going through. Beyond that, we often find that there are some family things that influence your stress response. For example, how your parents respond to stress will likely influence how you will. So if your parents withdrew and they put their head in the sand, you learn that that's an appropriate way to do it because it was the only way that was modeled to you. Or if your parents or your family with a kind of family that got angry and stressed and frustrated, you may struggle to control stress in yourself because, again, that outward, loud expression seemed normal and that influences our
记住这一点至关重要，以及你如何解读情况的威胁能力。所以你如何解读你的应对能力，以及你如何解读你所经历的事情有多可怕。除此之外，我们经常发现有一些家庭因素会影响你的压力反应。例如，你父母对压力的反应很可能会影响你的反应。所以如果你的父母选择退缩，把头埋在沙子里，你就会学到这是一种适当的方式，因为这是唯一向你展示的方式。或者如果你的父母或你的家庭是那种会生气、有压力和沮丧的家庭，你可能会难以控制自己的压力，因为同样，那种外向的、大声的表达似乎很正常，这会影响我们的
stress capacity. It is not always up to you how you respond to intense moments in your life or what your stress response is programmed to do. You know, it's often a hand-me-down. Your stress response is inherited. The second myth is that stress is everywhere and stress is inevitable. So you just have to live with it. That's all. This is both true and false at the same time. Stress is always going to occur. You are going to be stressed at times. That is the cost of engaging in life. Sometimes things are going to be difficult, including things that are really worth having. You know, also so much of our lives today, political instability, the cost of living, the fact that nobody can get a job, climate anxiety, rides of AI. I'm going to stop
压力容量。你如何应对生活中的强烈时刻，或者你的压力反应被编程为什么，并不总是由你决定的。你知道，这通常是代代相传的。你的压力反应是遗传的。第二个误区是压力无处不在，压力是不可避免的。所以你只能忍受它。仅此而已。这既是事实也是错误的。压力总是会发生的。你有时会感到压力。这是参与生活的代价。有时事情会很困难，包括那些真正值得拥有的事情。你知道，今天我们生活中的很多事情，政治不稳定、生活成本、没人能找到工作、气候焦虑、人工智能的兴起。我要停止
giving you a list and stressing you out more, but that often feels determined by things outside of our control, right? But there is a distinction between our reality and our reaction. Specifically, we have, or we are in control of what we call our cognitive appraisal. Cognitive appraisal is basically how you think about a situation. When we encounter some story about how AI is going to steal all of our jobs, or when we encounter our boss suddenly calling us at 8 a.m. in the morning, or a friend being like, I want to talk, we need to have a serious talk, right? We have two reactions. The first involves our primary appraisal. So this is the snap judgment or the instinct. 95% of the time, it is going to be more severe than the situation requires. Your instinct,
给你列清单让你更焦虑了，但这通常感觉是由我们无法控制的事情决定的，对吧？但我们的现实和我们的反应之间是有区别的。具体来说，我们拥有，或者我们控制着我们所谓的“认知评估”。认知评估基本上是你对情况的看法。当我们遇到关于人工智能将如何窃取我们所有工作的故事时，或者当我们遇到老板突然在早上8点打电话给我们时，或者朋友说“我想谈谈，我们需要进行一次严肃的谈话”，对吧？我们有两种反应。第一种涉及我们的初步评估。所以这是瞬间的判断或直觉。95%的情况下，它会比情况所要求的更严重。你的直觉，
your first appraisal, is going to be very intense because your body and your mind always prefers to overreact, then underreact for obvious reasons. The thing is, a lot of us will trust our primary appraisal and let that shape our mood and our reaction because we don't question our instinct. You have to go deeper into your secondary appraisal, though, if you actually want any chance of being able to choose your response to stress, which is what we're talking about today. And our secondary appraisal is when you evaluate your options. For example, you evaluate your the fact that, you know, I'm probably not thinking about this from all directions, and I'm probably undervaluing my ability to adapt and cope. I'm tough. I can get through this. I'm probably
你的第一次评估，会非常强烈，因为出于显而易见的原因，你的身体和大脑总是倾向于反应过度，而不是反应不足。问题是，我们很多人会相信我们的初步评估，并让它塑造我们的情绪和反应，因为我们不质疑我们的直觉。然而，如果你真的想有机会选择你对压力的反应——这正是我们今天谈论的内容——你就必须深入到你的二次评估中。我们的二次评估是你评估你的选择的时候。例如，你评估这样一个事实：你知道，我可能没有从各个方向考虑这个问题，我可能低估了我的适应和应对能力。我很坚强。我能度过难关。我可能
undervaluing what resources I have against this problem. I'm over-emphasizing the scary parts of this without considering the support I have, without considering the context, without considering the facts. Secondary appraisal is crucial, and this whole process, by the way, is known as Lazarus's transactional model of stress. And this filter can drastically change the direction of your stress and it can drastically change whether you are able to feel motivated by this moment or, I guess, despondent over it. So this is when we really get into the nitty gritty of what this whole episode is about. Can we turn bad stress into good stress? And is there a way of embracing this feeling specifically through the part of appraisal?
低估了我针对这个问题拥有的资源。我过分强调了这件可怕的事情，而没有考虑我拥有的支持，没有考虑背景，没有考虑事实。二次评估至关重要，顺便说一句，整个过程被称为拉扎勒斯的压力交易模型。这个过滤器可以极大地改变你压力的方向，它可以极大地改变你是否能够从这一刻感到动力，或者，我想，对它感到沮丧。所以这就是我们真正进入这一集核心内容的时候。我们能把坏压力变成好压力吗？有没有一种方法可以通过评估的部分专门拥抱这种感觉？
So before we spoke about the difference between you stress and distress, use stress being positive, distress being negative, to put it very, very simply. I probably made it seem like these were entirely context dependent. That is only partly true. Yes, if, I don't know, it's going to be hard not to experience distress if you've just gone through a breakup. And it's going to be hard to force use stress in response to losing your job. But the key difference between use stress and distress is,
所以之前我们谈到了良性压力和痛苦之间的区别，良性压力是积极的，痛苦是消极的，说得非常、非常简单。我可能让它们看起来完全取决于背景。这只是部分正确。是的，如果，我不知道，如果你刚经历了一次分手，很难不经历痛苦。而且在失业的情况下很难强迫自己产生良性压力。但良性压力和痛苦之间的关键区别在于，
what we just spoke about, which is perception and is the secondary appraisal. And this is really, really backed up by research. There was a very, very famous study from 2011, which highlighted how a positive reaction to stress can decrease distress and increase you stress if we use something known as the tend and befriend response. So when you experience stress, the best way to embrace this feeling or to just channel it in some way that's helpful is, to A, tend to something you care about, and B, be friend or be around others who can support you. The reason the tend and be friend response works so well in response to distress is because it is a reaction that focuses on expanding outwards rather than retracting inwards, which is typical
我们刚才谈到的，即感知和二次评估。这一点得到了研究的非常、非常强有力的支持。2011年有一项非常、非常著名的研究，强调了对压力的积极反应如何能减少痛苦并增加良性压力，如果我们使用一种被称为“照料与结盟”（tend and befriend）的反应。所以当你经历压力时，拥抱这种感觉或以某种有帮助的方式引导它的最好方法是：A，照料你在乎的事情；B，结盟或与能支持你的人在一起。“照料与结盟”反应在应对痛苦时如此有效的原因是，它是一种专注于向外扩展而不是向内收缩的反应，这在
when we approach a situation that's scary. Basically, it's productive rather than restrictive. And it also more importantly emphasizes the biggest antidote distress that we have, which is basically knowing that it's not just happening to you and that you have somebody else to share this feeling with. This model is incredibly effective and it's something that we don't often do. We experience stress as this all out negative feeling, not realizing that there are avenues through which to tackle it. And the best way to do that is to situate your stress in the context of relationships that you have and in the context of the social support that you have. And also in the context of knowing that
我们面对可怕的情况时很典型。基本上，它是建设性的而不是限制性的。而且更重要的是，它强调了我们拥有的对抗痛苦的最大解药，即基本上知道这不仅仅是发生在你一个人身上，而且你有其他人可以分享这种感觉。这个模型非常有效，是我们不常做的事情。我们把压力体验为一种完全的负面感觉，却没有意识到有多种途径可以解决它。最好的方法是将你的压力置于你拥有的人际关系背景下，以及你拥有的社会支持背景下。还要置于知道
whatever you are going through, even if you've made the biggest mistake, of your life, somebody's probably also gone through it and also everybody else has experienced perhaps something of a similar level. So in these conditions, when we are able to have a positive cognitive appraisal, when we can see stress as a challenge and when we adopt the tend and befriend model, that is when the benefits of stress emerge. That might still sound puzzling. probably like, well, what are you talking about? How can stress possibly be helpful? We're going to get to it. Stay with us. We'll be right back after this short break. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pesto
无论你正在经历什么，即使你犯了人生中最大的错误，可能也有人经历过，而且每个人可能都经历过类似程度的事情。因此，在这些条件下，当我们能够进行积极的认知评估时，当我们能把压力视为一种挑战时，当我们采用“照料与结盟”模型时，压力的好处就会显现出来。这听起来可能仍然令人困惑。可能像，“你在说什么？压力怎么可能有帮助？”我们要谈谈这个。请留下来。我们休息一下马上回来。在每天晚上为孩子们准备午餐的背后，隐藏着许多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？青酱
survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode eight before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Crave Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.com for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them.
能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒回家时是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？在你切黄瓜的时候，你能看完第8集吗？购买Bell纯光纤互联网，附赠Crave、Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。互联网价格保证两年，需签订两年合约并使用自动支付优惠。访问bell.com了解详情并查询覆盖范围。Bell，连接即一切。我14岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。
I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them.
我是Elizabeth Smart，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得耳边有一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说“闭嘴，什么都别说”。每周，我都会与那些经历过难以想象的事情的幸存者在一起。我当时就知道，如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始感觉到床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们曾被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些故事不是关于他们被夺走了什么，
There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of distance. course. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest
而是关于如何才能活着走出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Elizabeth Smart的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Pro Society》，这档每周播客既是读书俱乐部，也是群聊，适合那些思想深邃的人、流行文化痴迷者，以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《恋爱岛》具有同等讨论价值的人。我是Eli Rallo，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止谈论的对话之间的点点滴滴。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的BookTok创作者到最新的
pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a conversation, or a conversation, you're going to be a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place. Listen to Pro Society on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman.
流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以谈论的。这就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人入胜的角色中，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是仅仅是一次谈话，你都会加入一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你来对地方了。在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。书页间见。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。
Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal.
Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhain。Patrick McDonald。我们是《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》播客的主持人。这是一个即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都会有一组新的艺术家讨论他们的创作。加入我们，听听健康影响者的座谈会。我尝试做的是伪日记。
I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore. Okay. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class?
我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，是阅读。这叫阅读。所以我们不喜欢再用那个词了。好的。纽约客漫画家的座谈会。你们参加过Terry Gross的Peloton课程吗？
No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako in the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore. That's crazy. I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday, and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark Thirteen.
没有！我一直想去。我很抱歉。我正在Wonderland书店看Audra McDonald朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》。太疯狂了。我昨天去了Wonderland书店，我听说Nora Jones朗读了《猎杀本·拉登》。
No way. You have to come to the last bookstore, though. Kim Cottral is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. He gets right up next to the microphone.
不会吧。你一定要来最后一家书店。Kim Cottral正在朗读《昨日》的吉他谱。欧洲歌唱大赛参赛者的座谈会。我们有时也会搞点万圣节活动。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节会眨眼。他就在麦克风旁边。
I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on the I-Hurt radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle School is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend real time on it in our surviving middle school run,
我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。在I-Hurt Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艺术家谈艺术家谈艺术家》。到了11岁左右，至少70%的孩子有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时期完全不同的世界。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩的疗法》。我们在“幸存初中”系列中投入了真正的时间，
bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this seems to all this end up. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging.
请来了一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女孩的精神病学家，谈谈我们的孩子现在到底在经历什么。所以这简直是生理上、神经上、心理上的混乱，所有这些似乎都……所有这些最终都……我们深入探讨了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控和那种侵蚀信任的监视。还有归属感。
You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down with therapist Keer Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage. You don't have more shorts, so you're not. You can't do flips. You have on the dressy.
你可以把归属感理解为“我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受”。然后是“融入”。融入意味着“我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝”。然后我们将对话转向父亲们，与治疗师Keer Gaines坐下来谈谈黑人父亲身份，以及在这一阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。你没有更多的短裤了，所以你不能。你不能做后空翻。你穿的是裙子。
You have to cross your legs. That's the range of this run, from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. You have to get off her device. But the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their lives to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
你必须交叉双腿。这就是这一系列的范围，从屏幕时间到身份认同，再到在家中努力的父亲们。你必须让她离开设备。但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“幸存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯都在思考这些问题的人带给你。我是Joy博士。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《黑人女孩的疗法》。
So basically your perception of stress matters equally to the amount of stress that you are actually experiencing. I feel like I've made that point, but I just want to highlight one final study that confirms this, because I think it's like the best one. Probably should have included it first. Who cares? We're going to do it last. I've saved it to last for a reason. I'll pretend that's why we're talking about it now. But in 2012, there was a group of researchers who followed 30,000 adults in the US for eight years. The study, firstly asked, how much stress have you experienced in the last year? Secondly, they asked, do you believe that stress is harmful for your health? What they did next was that they used public
所以基本上，你对压力的感知与你实际经历的压力程度同样重要。我觉得我已经表达了这一点，但我只想强调最后一个证实这一点的研究，因为我觉得它是最好的一个。可能应该把它放在第一位。谁在乎呢？我们最后再说。我把它留到最后是有原因的。我会假装这就是我们现在谈论它的原因。但在2012年，有一组研究人员追踪了美国30,000名成年人，为期八年。这项研究首先问：你在过去一年里经历了多少压力？其次，他们问：你是否认为压力对你的健康有害？他们接下来做的是利用公共
death records to find out who from that group had essentially died prematurely. And researchers discovered many things, but two things that were very, very crucial. Firstly, they realized that those who had experienced severe stress in the previous year did have a 43% increased risk of dying prematurely. However, that was only true for those who believed that significant stress was bad for your health. Those who experienced severe stress but were able to appraise it and see it not as harmful but as helpful were no more likely to die in the follow-up. In fact, they actually have the lowest chance of dying prematurely out of anyone in the whole study, including those who experienced little to no stress in their life.
死亡记录来找出该群体中谁基本上过早死亡了。研究人员发现了许多事情，但有两点非常、非常关键。首先，他们意识到那些在过去一年中经历过严重压力的人确实有43%的过早死亡风险增加。然而，这只对那些认为重大压力对健康有害的人来说是真实的。那些经历过严重压力但能够评估它并将其视为有帮助而不是有害的人，在随访中死亡的可能性并没有增加。事实上，他们实际上是整个研究中过早死亡几率最低的人，包括那些生活中几乎没有压力的人。
Our stress response can become healthier over time when we retrain our brains to recognize that our bodies in these moments are trying to help, not trying to hinder us, and also when we have that critical appraisal capability. When we do this, we rewire our reaction, which can elevate or decrease stress significantly, potentially saving us from so many physical and mental health kind of secondary effects that create and come about as a result of chronic stress. Now, a big fat disclaimer here, can perception alone eliminate the impact of a chronically stressful job or a chronically stressful environment or a chronically stressful financial situation or relationship.
我们的压力反应随着时间的推移会变得更健康，当我们重新训练我们的大脑去认识到我们在这些时刻的身体是在试图帮助我们，而不是试图阻碍我们，并且当我们拥有那种关键的评估能力时。当我们这样做时，我们重塑了我们的反应，这可以显著提升或降低压力，可能使我们免受许多因慢性压力而产生的身体和心理健康方面的次要影响。现在，这里有一个大大的免责声明，仅靠感知能消除一份压力巨大的工作、一个压力巨大的环境或一个压力巨大的经济状况或关系的影响吗？
No, it just cannot. I want to be really clear. Mindset can only go so far. But this is where we need to understand another important theory, which is known as the Yerk Dodson's law or Yerk's Dostens theory. What it says is that each of us has an optimal level of stress, which will be advantageous. This law, this model, is basically. basically a theory of the relationship between stress and performance. And it's a model that's
不，它不能。我想说得很清楚。心态只能起到一定作用。但这就是我们需要理解另一个重要理论的地方，即所谓的“耶基斯-多德森定律”（Yerkes-Dodson law）或耶基斯-多德森理论。它说的是，我们每个人都有一个最佳压力水平，这将是有利的。这个定律，这个模型，基本上是关于压力和表现之间关系的理论。这是一个模型，
been around since like, I think it literally is one of the earliest psychological model that's been around since like the early 1900s. It was pioneered by these two men, Robert Yerkes, John Dilligan Dodson. And this model basically proposes that you reach your peak level of performance with an intermediate level of stress or arousal. Too little or too much stress is what results in poor performance and perhaps poor health. You and I can see this in ourselves, right? Stress has an optimal level. And if you were going to try to eradicate all stress,
自1900年代初以来就一直存在，我想它确实是最早的心理学模型之一。它由Robert Yerkes和John Dilligan Dodson这两位男士开创。这个模型基本上提出，你在中等水平的压力或唤醒下达到表现的巅峰水平。太少或太多的压力会导致表现不佳，甚至健康状况不佳。你和我都能在自己身上看到这一点，对吧？压力有一个最佳水平。如果你试图消除所有的压力，
A, what would happen is that any experience of stress would immediately actually become distressed rather than you stress because we'd be so unable to cope with it and so ashamed of it that we're feeling this thing that we're not meant to be feeling, that we just literally would not know what to do. And B, we would also lose a vital psychological. motivational motivator. When you are faced with a deadline or a really challenging task or anything that's difficult, the pressure you feel, we know this can push you to work harder and perform better than usual.
A，会发生的是，任何压力体验都会立即变成痛苦而不是良性压力，因为我们将无法应对它，并为我们感到这种不该有的感觉而感到羞耻，以至于我们真的不知道该怎么办。B，我们也会失去一个至关重要的心理动力。当你面临截止日期或一项非常具有挑战性的任务或任何困难的事情时，你感受到的压力，我们知道这可以推动你比平时更努力地工作，表现得更好。
That is stress that is making you do that. When you face stress in a relationship, you know, that's also a motivator. It's a sign that something needs fixing and it is a force to do so to eliminate this bad feeling. And it makes our brain more focused. It makes our brain more attentive. stress is an indicator of what to pay attention to, and that is critical. So the final point I need to make here is that when we villainize stress in its entirety or when we are intensely focused on eliminating all stress and being regulated at all time, we often forget that this alternative would likely not serve us either. When we have too little stimulation, too little challenge or demand placed on us,
那是压力在促使你这样做。当你面对一段关系中的压力时，你知道，那也是一种动力。这是一个信号，表明有些事情需要修复，这是一种消除这种坏感觉的力量。它使我们的大脑更专注。它使我们的大脑更警觉。压力是一个需要注意什么的指标，这一点至关重要。所以我在这里需要做的最后一点是，当我们全盘妖魔化压力，或者当我们专注于消除所有压力并时刻保持调节时，我们经常忘记这种替代方案也可能对我们没有帮助。当我们受到的刺激太少，受到的挑战或要求太少时，
we drift towards the opposite end of the stress spectrum, which is, stagnation, boredom, apathy, and disengagement. I think it's important to think about those periods in your life when you had absolutely nothing to do for days on end and you weren't on holiday, you weren't really doing anything. At first, like, it feels incredible, but eventually you start to feel really, really different and strange and kind of unhappy.
我们就会漂向压力谱的另一端，即停滞、无聊、冷漠和脱节。我认为思考一下你生活中那些连续几天无事可做，又不是在度假，也没做什么事情的时期是很重要的。起初，感觉棒极了，但最终你开始感到非常、非常不同、奇怪，而且有点不快乐。
And there's a reason for that. Our body craves a certain level of activation, and it needs a certain level of activation to be interested and engaged with our lives. even if your level may be less than somebody else's, you still need something. You still need some kind of stimulus. And this is the biggest problem with trying to avoid stress entirely. Avoiding stress will make your world smaller. It just simply will. Some of the best parts of life are going to be the most stressful, like getting married, like traveling, like big life changes, moving cities. Those are great things. So avoiding stress would have you avoid.
这是有原因的。我们的身体渴望一定程度的激活，它需要一定程度的激活才能对我们的生活感兴趣并参与其中。即使你的水平可能比别人的低，你仍然需要一些东西。你仍然需要某种刺激。这就是试图完全避免压力的最大问题。避免压力会让你的世界变得更小。它确实会。生活中一些最美好的部分将是最有压力的，比如结婚、旅行、重大的生活变化、搬到不同的城市。那些都是伟大的事情。所以避免压力会让你避免
your greatest potential for change and your greatest potential for new memories. And this is why we have to distinguish between stress, growth, and homeostasis, because they all operate separately and together. Homeostasis is your body's tendency to maintain stability and to return to a comfortable baseline where things are very predictable and safe and stress is minimal. We need that, but we cannot permanently live there the same way that we cannot permanently live in a place of heightened stress. You need stress because growth often requires temporarily moving away from that homeostasis
你最大的改变潜力和你最大的新记忆潜力。这就是为什么我们必须区分压力、成长和稳态，因为它们既独立运作又相互关联。稳态是你身体维持稳定并回到舒适基线的倾向，在那里事情是非常可预测和安全的，压力是最小的。我们需要那个，但我们不能永久地生活在那里，就像我们不能永久地生活在高度压力的状态下一样。你需要压力，因为成长通常需要暂时离开那种稳态。
or that or that baseline. When you're learning something difficult, when you're exercising, when you're traveling somewhere unfamiliar, when you're meeting new people, when you are starting a new job, that uncomfortable feeling is critical for the experience. Like all those things can create physiological and psychological stress, not because they are bad things, but because they demand. and adaptation. And adaptation and struggle is a major sign of personal evolution. And also, it's probably the only pathway to growing as an individual and growing as a human. So we need to be
或者那种基准线。当你学习困难的东西时，当你锻炼时，当你去陌生的地方旅行时，当你结识新朋友时，当你开始一份新工作时，那种不舒服的感觉对这种体验至关重要。就像所有这些事情都会产生生理和心理压力，不是因为它们是坏事，而是因为它们需要适应。而适应和挣扎是个人进化的一个重要标志。而且，这可能是作为个体和人类成长的唯一途径。所以我们需要
really, really critical in remembering that. When somebody says, I want to eliminate all stress, I want my nervous system to be completely regulated, not having any stress in your 20s at any time is actually really bad for you and will actually mean that your life is smaller. So how do we leverage the good parts of stress? How do we leverage only the stress that we want, knowing that we have to kind of have a relationship with stress in order to get its benefits? Let's talk about it. Firstly, I think the biggest way to change our relationship to stress is to change our mindset. Stress is not a weakness. It's physiology. A little bit of stress is going to be good for you. You cannot grow without tension or friction. Your stress is indicative that you are putting
非常、非常关键地记住这一点。当有人说，我想消除所有的压力，我想让我的神经系统完全调节好，在20多岁时完全没有压力实际上对你非常有害，这意味着你的生活会变得狭隘。那么我们如何利用压力的好的一面呢？我们如何只利用我们想要的压力，同时知道我们必须与压力建立某种关系才能获得它的好处？让我们谈谈这个问题。首先，我认为改变我们与压力关系的最大方法是改变我们的心态。压力不是一种弱点。它是生理机能。一点点压力对你有好处。没有紧张或摩擦，你就无法成长。你的压力表明你正在
yourself in environments where growth is possible. And also, stress is half reality, half reaction. Those are all critical things that need to be remembered in order for your mindset around stress to change. Instead of viewing it as a threat, we need to look at it as an opportunity for growth. For instance, we often associate, I think, a lot of the physical symptoms of stress negatively because they indicate that something is off in within ourselves or off in our environment. Things aren't balanced. And that's not something that people like to feel. We don't like to feel our heart pounding.
把自己置于可能成长的环境中。而且，压力一半是现实，一半是反应。为了改变你对压力的心态，这些都是必须记住的关键点。我们不应该把它视为一种威胁，而应该把它视为成长的机会。例如，我认为我们经常消极地联想压力的许多身体症状，因为它们表明我们自身内部或环境中出现了问题。事情失去了平衡。这不是人们喜欢的感觉。我们不喜欢感觉到心跳加速。
We don't like to feel jittery or sweaty. But as I've said on this podcast before, those physical reactions aren't just activated by stress, right? They are also activated by excitement and they are also activated by anticipation. Those are emotional states that we view pretty positively and that are pretty great. So if we can interrupt our thoughts before they get to these feelings of stress and label them as bad and instead label them as something that is exciting, rewarding or a sign of something really big and marvelous on the horizon, the painful side effects of stress, particularly
我们不喜欢感到紧张或出汗。但正如我之前在这个播客中所说，这些身体反应不仅仅是由压力激活的，对吧？它们也由兴奋激活，也由期待激活。这些是我们认为相当积极且非常棒的情绪状态。因此，如果我们能在压力感产生之前打断我们的想法，不把它们贴上坏的标签，而是把它们贴上令人兴奋、有益或地平线上有重大而美妙的事情的标志，那么压力的痛苦副作用，特别是
distress, are minimized without completely eliminating or villainizing the reaction as a whole. Next, I think to change our relationship to stress, we need to reframe how we approach goal setting and tasks and how we celebrate our wins, which I know it sounds cheesy, you know it sounds very like self-helpy, but we'll actually deeply change your relationship to stress and your ability to kind of find your cognitive and psychological sweet spot and your ideal level of arousal and activation. So one way that we can do this is to create containers for our stress, or basically limit how much stress a task can create before it is completed.
痛苦，就会在不完全消除或妖魔化整个反应的情况下被最小化。接下来，我认为要改变我们与压力的关系，我们需要重新构建我们处理目标设定和任务的方式，以及我们庆祝胜利的方式，我知道这听起来很俗气，听起来很像自助建议，但它实际上会深刻地改变你与压力的关系，以及你找到认知和心理最佳点以及理想唤醒和激活水平的能力。所以我们可以做到这一点的一种方法是为我们的压力创造容器，或者基本上限制一个任务在完成之前可以产生多少压力。
The critical way to think about this is the difference between putting, what's a good example? The difference between putting like, get my finances together on your to-do list and step one, check bank balance. Step two, cancel unnecessary subscriptions. Step three, set up automatic transfer to savings. Step four, watch one YouTube video on investing. There is a big difference in those two things. One of them feels like more because there's four things to do. but the first one is actually more daunting.
思考这个问题的关键方式是区分，什么是一个好的例子？区分把“整理好我的财务”放在你的待办事项清单上，和第一步，检查银行余额。第二步，取消不必要的订阅。第三步，设置自动转账到储蓄账户。第四步，看一个关于投资的YouTube视频。这两者之间有很大的区别。其中一个感觉更多，因为有四件事要做，但第一个实际上更令人望而生畏。
The first task has almost no boundaries. Your brain is holding an entire goal in mind at once, including every single moment of uncertainty, every single decision that you still need to make, every possible thing that could go wrong, every single step. And it becomes this huge open loop and open space that can generate stress for hours, days, weeks,
第一个任务几乎没有界限。你的大脑同时保持着一个完整的目标，包括每一个不确定的时刻，每一个你仍然需要做的决定，每一件可能出错的事情，每一个步骤。它变成了一个巨大的开放循环和开放空间，可以在数小时、数天、数周内产生压力，
because it's going to take that long to complete the task. Figure out my finances is not a one-day event. But when you break that goal into smaller chunks, you also break the stress into smaller chunks as well. Instead of needing enough psychological capacity to deal with an entire life and financial reset, you only need enough capacity to check your bank balance just for today. And that might be stressful. It probably is. But the time horizon for the peak of that stress and how long it takes for it to eventually subside is much, much smaller.
因为它需要那么长时间才能完成任务。“弄清楚我的财务状况”不是一天就能完成的事情。但当你把那个目标分解成更小的块时，你也把压力分解成了更小的块。你不需要足够的心理能力来处理整个生活和财务重置，你只需要足够的心理能力来检查今天的银行余额。这可能会有压力。很可能确实如此。但这种压力达到顶峰的时间跨度以及它最终消退所需的时间要小得多。
That is the container. the task is the container. It has a clear beginning, and importantly, it has a clear end, and the beginning and the end are much closer together than a big open-ended goal. I think this is particularly useful when, just whenever something feels overwhelming, I think a lot of the time we ask ourselves, like, oh my God, how am I going to finish this and how am I going to get there as fast as possible? If you ask yourself instead, like, what is the smallest, complete unit of this task that I can focus on right now, you are reducing how much of that work your brain has to emotionally carry at one time that could push you over your stress threshold. And that I think can be
这就是容器。任务就是容器。它有一个明确的开始，重要的是，它有一个明确的结束，而且开始和结束比一个大的开放式目标要近得多。我认为这特别有用，当任何事情让人感到不知所措时，我认为很多时候我们问自己，天哪，我该怎么完成这个，我该怎么尽快到达那里？如果你问自己，我此刻可以专注于这个任务的最小、最完整的单位是什么，你就在减少你的大脑必须一次性在情感上承担多少工作，这可能会把你推向压力阈值。我认为这可能是
the difference between having a kind of stress that paralyzes us and stops us from performing and having a kind of stress response that actually helps us perform and helps us get through things and do things that we need to do. Okay, we're going to take one more short break. Then we're going to dive into the final two ways that we can embrace stress and also how we know when our stress is getting too great because there's obviously that's out of this discussion as well. So stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode eight before you're done slicing the
那种让我们瘫痪并阻止我们表现的压力，与那种实际上帮助我们表现并帮助我们度过难关、完成我们需要做的事情的压力反应之间的区别。好了，我们要再休息一小会儿。然后我们将深入探讨我们可以拥抱压力的最后两种方式，以及我们如何知道我们的压力何时变得太大，因为显然这也是本次讨论的一部分。所以请留下来。在每个为孩子们准备午餐的夜晚背后，都有很多悬念。他们最终会吃蔬菜吗？意大利面能撑过第一口吗？午餐盒会空着回来，半满回来，还是根本回不来？你会在切完之前看完第八集吗？
cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet. with craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything.
黄瓜？获取Bell纯光纤互联网。包含Netflix和Disney Plus，每月94美元起。互联网两年期合同及自动支付信用额度，价格保证两年。访问bell.ca了解详情并检查可用性。Bell，连接就是一切。
When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember, This low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable.
我14岁时被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我活了下来，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。我只记得，耳边那个低沉、嘲弄的声音说，闭嘴，什么都别说。每周，我都会和经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起。
I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me. I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives,
我知道如果他醒了，毫无疑问，他会伤害我。我开始觉得床尾有人，我就开始尖叫。他们被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。但这些不是关于他们被夺走了什么的故事。而是关于他们如何活着走出来的故事。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。这是《Prose Society》，这是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，又是思想女儿、流行文化痴迷者的群聊，
and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of disfews. course. I'm Eli Rallo and every week we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table. It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place.
以及任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱之岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。我是Eli Rallo，每周我们都在连接书籍、互联网和每个人都无法停止讨论的话题。我得去查查这个故事。我着迷了。从畅销书作家和你最喜欢的书评创作者到最新的流行文化时刻，没有什么是不可以讨论的。这就像如果你能把一些真实的信息隐藏在引人入胜的角色中，那么这就是特洛伊木马。无论你是在寻找文学深度解析、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢思考太多的读者社区，你都来对地方了。
Listen to Pro Society on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. See you between the pages. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angel Geratana. Jeremy Colhain. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcast
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Prose Society》。在书页间见。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angel Geratana。Jeremy Colhain。Patrick McDonald。我们是《Artists on Artists on Artists on Artists》播客的主持人。即兴角色喜剧播客
where each week a new panel of artists discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of wellness influencers. What I try to do is faux journal. I don't know. Have you guys heard of faux journaling? Yeah, it's reading. It's called reading. So we don't like to use that word anymore.
每周都有一个新的艺术家小组讨论他们的手艺。加入我们的健康影响者小组。我尝试做的是伪日记。我不知道。你们听说过伪日记吗？是的，那是阅读。它叫阅读。所以我们不喜欢再用那个词了。
Okay. A panel of New Yorker cartoonists. Have you guys done Terry Gross's Peloton class? No! I've been dying too. I'm so sorry. I'm seeing a reading of Sadako and the Thousand Paper Cranes by Audra McDonald's at the Wonderland Bookstore on 14. That's crazy.
好的。《纽约客》漫画家小组。你们做过Terry Gross的Peloton课程吗？没有！我一直想做。我很抱歉。我正在第14街的仙境书店看Audra McDonald朗读《佐佐子与一千只纸鹤》。太疯狂了。
I went to the Wonderland Bookstore yesterday, and I heard Nora Jones do a reading of Zero Dark 30. No way. You have to come to the last bookstore, though. Kim Cottrell is reading the guitar tabs of yesterday. A panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween.
我昨天去了仙境书店，我听到了Nora Jones朗读《猎杀本·拉登》。不会吧。你一定要来最后一家书店。Kim Cottrell正在朗读《昨日》的吉他谱。欧洲歌唱大赛参与者小组。我们有时会做一点万圣节活动。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。
It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to artists on artists on artists on the I-Hurt radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcasts. By age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. Middle School is a different world than the one we grew up in. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls.
就在麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。在I-Hurt广播应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Artists on Artists on Artists》。大约11岁左右，至少70%的人有手机。初中是一个与我们成长时期不同的世界。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩的治疗》。
We spend real time on it in our surviving middle school run, bringing in a child psychologist and a psychiatrist who's raising two black girls of his own to talk about what's really going on with our kids right now. So it's literally physiological and neurological and psychological and psychological chaos happening all this same job. We got into group chats and gaming, friendships and bullying, and how to tell the difference between healthy monitoring
我们在我们的“幸存初中”系列中花费了真正的时间，请来了一位儿童心理学家和一位正在抚养两个黑人女儿的精神科医生，谈论我们的孩子现在到底发生了什么。所以这简直是生理、神经和心理上的混乱，同时发生。我们讨论了群聊和游戏、友谊和欺凌，以及如何区分健康的监控
and the kind of surveillance that erodes trust. There's belonging. You could think of belonging as I can be myself and I can still be accepted. And then there's fitting in. Spitting in says I have to change who I am in order to avoid rejection. Then we turn the conversation toward the fathers, sitting down with therapists Keer Gaines on Black fatherhood and what it means to raise a daughter through this stage.
和那种侵蚀信任的监视。有归属感。你可以把归属感理解为我可以做我自己，我仍然可以被接受。然后是融入。融入意味着我必须改变我是谁，以避免被拒绝。然后我们将对话转向父亲，与治疗师Keer Gaines坐下来谈论黑人父亲身份，以及在这个阶段抚养女儿意味着什么。
You don't have more shorts, so you can't do flips. You have on the dressy, so you can cross your legs. That's the range of this run, from screen time to identity to the father's doing the work at home. You have to get off her device.
你没有更多的短裤，所以你不能做后空翻。你穿着裙子，所以你可以交叉双腿。这就是这个系列的范围，从屏幕时间到身份，再到在家工作的父亲。你必须让她离开她的设备。
But the reality is there's a lot of life out there that we don't want you as your adults in their lives to miss out on. This has been our surviving middle school run. Brought to you by the people who spend their careers thinking about exactly this. I'm Dr. Joy. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
但现实是，外面有很多生活，我们不希望你们作为他们生活中的成年人错过。这就是我们的“幸存初中”系列。由那些职业生涯都在思考这个问题的人带给你。我是Joy博士。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《黑人女孩的治疗》。
So the third way that we're going to learn to embrace stress from a psychological standpoint is to basically just move with your stress. Your stress wants you to do something about it. It wants you to pay attention to it. It's basically saying, hey, I've just given you all this adrenaline and I've given you all this glucose and all this energy and all this motivation and I've made you very, very scared. So use that feeling. Use me.
所以我们从心理学角度学习拥抱压力的第三种方式是基本上随着你的压力而动。你的压力希望你对它做点什么。它希望你关注它。它基本上是在说，嘿，我刚刚给了你所有这些肾上腺素，我给了你所有这些葡萄糖、所有这些能量和所有这些动力，我让你非常、非常害怕。所以利用那种感觉。利用我。
Take advantage of this. I understand the feeling to take stress and sit with it and ruminate over it and try and mentally problem solve it or think our way out of it. But unfortunately, that does not work because that is not the plane upon which stress operates. Stress is operating at a biological level. You're trying to deal with it on a cognitive level. Stress activates your systems for a reason. And that is why when you are suddenly overwhelmed, you know, we feel like we need to pace and we get twitchy and we, our heart rate
利用这一点。我理解那种承受压力并与之共处、反复思考并试图在心理上解决它或想出办法的感觉。但不幸的是，这行不通，因为那不是压力运作的层面。压力是在生物层面运作的。你试图在认知层面处理它。压力激活你的系统是有原因的。这就是为什么当你突然不知所措时，你知道，我们觉得我们需要踱步，我们变得抽搐，我们，我们的心率
jump in and we need to move about. As much as your cognitive appraisal is important, just existing in that physical reaction is also important. Don't fight the feeling. When you have it, channel it into doing something that you feel like you haven't had the time to do. Brainstorm a game plan for yourself. Answer all your messages, do all your chores. Channel it into something productive. This is actually something that the Stanford psychologist and stress expert, Alea Crum, what calls utilising stress. The practical question she asked is essentially, how can I use the energy created by stressful situations
跳动，我们需要走动。尽管你的认知评估很重要，但仅仅存在于那种身体反应中也很重要。不要抗拒这种感觉。当你拥有它时，把它引导到做一些你觉得你一直没时间做的事情上。为自己构思一个行动计划。回复你所有的信息，做你所有的家务。把它引导到有成效的事情上。这实际上是斯坦福大学心理学家和压力专家Alea Crum所说的利用压力。她提出的实际问题本质上是，我如何利用压力情境产生的能量
to move towards what matters to me rather than to stay in a place of that stress? Again, it comes back to the opportunity mindset. I'm stressed. Oh my God. What am I going to do? I can't outthink it. Let's run with this for a while.
来朝着对我重要的事情前进，而不是停留在那种压力的地方？同样，这又回到了机会心态。我有压力。天哪。我该怎么办？我无法超越它。让我们带着这个跑一会儿。
I've got all these things I need to get done. What a great time to do them. But my body is naturally working at a more efficient pace. I find this particularly useful as a ruminator. My previous response to stress or worry or anxiety was just to kind of sit and mull and be like, I can problem solve my way out of this and I think any overthinker will relate. I think it's very easy to believe that if you are a smart person or an overachiever, like you can intellectualize your feelings and that there is a solution that just requires you to think harder. But the secret solution here is moving through or flowing with your
我有很多事情需要完成。做这些事情真是个好时机。但我的身体自然地以更高效的节奏工作。我发现这对于一个反复思考者特别有用。我之前对压力、担忧或焦虑的反应只是坐着琢磨，觉得我可以解决这个问题，我想任何过度思考者都会有共鸣。我认为很容易相信，如果你是一个聪明人或追求卓越的人，你可以理智化你的感受，并且有一个解决方案只需要你更努力地思考。但这里的秘密解决方案是经历或顺应你的
stress rather than trying to figure it out mentally. And I, really do like to think about it as like a dance. Like I'm doing this like salsa dance with my stress until my stress, the partner, gets bored of itself or ties out and then I can have that cognitive appraisal where I can deal with the situation better. This brings me to my final point for this episode, which also comes from Crum's work. She's pretty cool. She does some really cool stuff. And what she basically says is if you want to manage your stress, stop managing other people's stress. Sometimes the most stressful thing that happens to us is that we see other people's stress as our own responsibility. I'm going to make a bet that you are a very sensitive person,
压力，而不是试图在心理上弄清楚它。我真的喜欢把它想象成一种舞蹈。就像我和我的压力在跳萨尔萨舞，直到我的压力，那个伙伴，对自己感到厌倦或疲惫，然后我就可以进行那种认知评估，我可以更好地处理这种情况。这让我谈到了本集的最后一点，这也来自Crum的研究。她很酷。她做了一些非常酷的事情。她基本上说的是，如果你想管理你的压力，就停止管理别人的压力。有时发生在我们身上最令人压力的事情是我们把别人的压力视为我们自己的责任。我敢打赌你是一个非常敏感的人，
you are a very caring person. And if you are this kind of person, your instinct when other people are feeling overwhelmed or stressed is often to immediately make their problem and their stress disappear. This often sounds like, you know, oh, don't worry, I'll just do it for you. Let me plan this, let me take over, I'll make this all better. And it comes from an incredibly loving place, but constantly sheltering people from their own situation and from their stress can accidentally create or reinforce this belief that stress is something that they cannot handle, whilst also pushing you beyond your threshold or your window for tolerance much, much easier, meaning that nobody is better off. Sometimes our job is to realize that people are responsible for
你是一个非常有爱心的人。如果你是这种人，当别人感到不知所措或有压力时，你的本能通常是立即让他们的麻烦和压力消失。这通常听起来像，你知道，哦，别担心，我帮你做。让我来计划这个，让我来接手，我会让这一切变得更好。这来自一个极其充满爱心的地方，但不断地保护人们免受他们自己的处境和压力的影响，可能会意外地创造或加强这种信念，即压力是他们无法处理的事情，同时也让你更容易超出你的阈值或容忍窗口，这意味着没有人会更好。有时我们的工作是意识到人们要对
their own emotions and their own solutions to those emotions. We can be part of the tend and befriend process. We can help them out. We can sit with them like we spoke about before. But this immediate instinct to problem solve reinforces a general belief that all stress is bad. And that is simply incorrect. Psychology says something different as well. Decades of research show that the best thing that you as a friend or as a kind person can do for somebody else's stress, whether it's a partner or your parents or your sibling or whatever, is just to be physically present without always being cognitively problem solving. We call this social buffering and it essentially says,
他们自己的情绪以及解决这些情绪的方法负责。我们可以成为照顾和结交过程的一部分。我们可以帮助他们。我们可以像之前说的那样和他们坐在一起。但这种立即解决问题的本能加强了一种普遍的信念，即所有的压力都是坏的。这显然是不正确的。心理学也说了不同的东西。几十年的研究表明，作为朋友或善良的人，你能为别人的压力做的最好的事情，无论是伴侣、父母、兄弟姐妹还是其他什么人，仅仅是在身体上在场，而不总是进行认知上的问题解决。我们称之为社会缓冲，它本质上说，
or we essentially know that just the presence or existence of a support network makes stress more manageable and more likely to be what we call a motivational force rather than a corrosive one or a mentally taxing one. If you love somebody, the kindest thing you can do is validate that they can survive this situation themselves. That is actually such a kindness to not always problem solve, but to be beside them, to validate that it's difficult, to help where help is actually needed,
或者我们本质上知道，仅仅是支持网络的存在或存在就使压力更易于管理，并且更有可能成为我们所说的动力，而不是腐蚀性的或精神上繁重的。如果你爱某人，你能做的最善良的事情就是确认他们自己可以度过这种情况。不总是解决问题，而是站在他们身边，确认这很困难，在真正需要帮助的地方提供帮助，这实际上是一种极大的善良，
but to just give them the opportunity to discover their own capacity. Every time we move through something stressful and we realized like, oh my God, I actually handled that really, really well. Wait, maybe I needed that experience. Like, maybe I'm actually more capable than I think. We acquire this evidence that we're really, really capable people and that we actually can really go after what we want and we can handle a lot more than we think.
但只是给他们机会去发现他们自己的能力。每次我们经历一些有压力的事情，我们意识到，天哪，我实际上处理得非常好。等等，也许我需要那种体验。也许我实际上比我想象的更有能力。我们获得了这种证据，证明我们是非常、非常有能力的人，我们实际上真的可以追求我们想要的，我们可以处理比我们想象的更多的事情。
That is so, so critical. So I think that that's an equally part of this stress conversation is not only how do you manage your stress, what is your immediate reaction to manage? somebody else's stress for them? And how is that reinforcing your own belief that stress is this terrible bad thing that could never possibly have a benefit? So as we kind of finish up this episode, I want to offer one final little caveat here, a little disclaimer, if you will, and a summary all in one, we're going to do it altogether. What I really want you to take away
这非常、非常关键。所以我认为这也是压力对话中同样重要的一部分，不仅是你如何管理你的压力，你管理别人压力的直接反应是什么？这如何加强了你自己的信念，即压力是这种永远不可能有好处的可怕坏事？所以当我们结束这一集时，我想在这里提供最后一个小警告，如果你愿意的话，一个免责声明，以及一个总结，我们一起做。我真正想让你带走的是
that we've learned from the research is that we instinctually villainize stress because it feels intense and because sometimes it is. It is not good for us emotionally, psychologically, physically, socially to be in a constant state of stress all the time. Your growth in these situations has a psychological ceiling. Additionally, there is no mindset shift in this world that can eradicate the chronic stress of a toxic home life, a bad relationship, a terrible financial situation, a natural disaster, terrible environmental things happening to you. There's nothing that can, like, cognitively get you out of that. And there's nothing that, like, can be said to be like, oh, now your stress is going to go away. Congratulations. However, to go through life and to go
我们从研究中学到的，我们本能地妖魔化压力，因为它感觉强烈，而且有时确实如此。一直处于持续的压力状态对我们在情感、心理、身体、社交上都没有好处。你在这些情况下的成长有一个心理上限。此外，世界上没有任何心态转变可以根除有毒家庭生活、糟糕的关系、可怕的财务状况、自然灾害、发生在你身上的可怕环境事物的慢性压力。没有什么可以，像，在认知上让你摆脱那种困境。也没有什么可以，像，被说成是，哦，现在你的压力会消失了。恭喜。然而，如果一生都
through your 20s without stress of any kind would also be somewhat tragic because you would be missing your body's, A, its most ancient survival mechanism, and you would also be missing a mental state that accompanies so many of life's highest peak expansive moments. The stress we would prefer to experience in these moments is you stress, but we can also change the emotional charge of our stress through that secondary appraisal or cognitive appraisal overall, and by doing so through those four strategies that I mentioned, which is to change your mindset, change your approach to goal setting and create stress containers, move with your stress, not against it,
经历20多岁而没有任何压力也会有些悲剧，因为你会错过你身体的，A，它最古老的生存机制，你也会错过伴随许多人生最高峰扩张时刻的精神状态。我们在这些时刻更愿意体验的压力是积极压力，但我们也可以通过那种二次评估或整体认知评估来改变我们压力的情绪负荷，并通过我提到的那四种策略来做到这一点，即改变你的心态，改变你设定目标的方法并创造压力容器，随着你的压力而动，而不是对抗它，
and remember that other people are responsible for their own emotional reaction. Your job is not to make everyone else less stressed and yourself more stressed. It's also not to eradicate stress. I think it's just like to exist and make the most of the stress that you have and make the most of the ways that you can channel it positively if that is available to you. So that, my friends, is the episode. Our new approach to embracing stress. Thank you to our researcher Lucy for helping us with this one.
并记住其他人要对他们自己的情绪反应负责。你的工作不是让每个人都压力更小而你自己压力更大。也不是要根除压力。我认为这就像存在并充分利用你拥有的压力，如果可能的话，充分利用你可以积极引导它的方式。所以，我的朋友们，这就是这一集。我们拥抱压力的新方法。感谢我们的研究员Lucy帮助我们完成了这一集。
I hope you enjoyed it. I hope you learned something. If you feel called to do so and you find that these episodes are valuable to you and you get knowledge from them, you can leave a five-star review. You can leave a comment down below about what are you going to get out of your stress this week? Leave a little comment if you're listening on Spotify. Quick reminder, you can also. watch this episode and many others just like it on Netflix. You can follow us on Instagram,
我希望你喜欢它。我希望你学到了一些东西。如果你觉得有必要这样做，并且你发现这些剧集对你有价值，并且你从中获得了知识，你可以留下五星好评。你可以在下面留下评论，关于你这周将从你的压力中获得什么？如果你在Spotify上收听，留下一个小评论。快速提醒，你也可以在Netflix上观看这一集和许多其他类似的剧集。你可以在Instagram上关注我们，
on Substack. You can read some of the research that I mentioned in the description. There's a lot down there. You can buy my book. You can follow me on Instagram. I don't really post anything that interesting, but I don't know if you want to see what's going on over there. It's all going to be there. And I just hope that you enjoyed this episode and that it kind I gave you a new outlook on stress without being too kind of toxic positivity for you. I hope I walked that line well. And yeah, I don't know. I hope you enjoyed the research.
在Substack上。你可以阅读我在描述中提到的一些研究。下面有很多。你可以买我的书。你可以在Instagram上关注我。我并没有发布什么特别有趣的东西，但我不知道你是否想看看那边发生了什么。一切都会在那里。我只是希望你喜欢这一集，并且它给了你一个关于压力的新视角，而不会对你产生太多的有毒积极性。我希望我很好地把握了那条线。是的，我不知道。我希望你喜欢这项研究。
So until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hi, this is Kylie Breakman. Angela Geratana. Jeremy Colhane. Patrick McDonald. And we're the hosts of the Artists on Artists on Artists Podcast. The Improvised Character Comedy Podcasts where each week a new panel of artists
所以直到下次，保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。嗨，我是Kylie Breakman。Angela Geratana。Jeremy Colhane。Patrick McDonald。我们是《Artists on Artists on Artists》播客的主持人。即兴角色喜剧播客，每周都有一个新的艺术家小组
discuss their craft. Join us for a panel of Eurovision participants. And we do a little Halloween sometimes. Does the Pope dress up? He winks on Halloween. It's right up next to the microphone. I hear you can almost hear the eyelashes hit each other. You never seen Italy so quiet
讨论他们的手艺。加入我们的欧洲歌唱大赛参与者小组。我们有时会做一点万圣节活动。教皇会打扮吗？他在万圣节眨眼。就在麦克风旁边。我听说你几乎能听到睫毛撞击的声音。你从未见过意大利
as when the Pope gets up to wink on Halloween. Listen to Artists on Artists on Artists every Thursday on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive.
像教皇在万圣节眨眼时那样安静。每周四在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Artists on Artists on Artists》。我在囚禁中幸存了九个月，我一生都在探索其他人是如何在应该摧毁他们的情况下幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯马特，这是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都会和经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起，被绑架、跟踪、控制，几乎被噤声。这些是关于他们如何活着走出来的故事。
Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island to serve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought. opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听伊丽莎白·斯马特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和你的“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。《Prose Society》是一个每周播客，既是读书俱乐部，又是群聊，适合任何认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱之岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。每周，我们都在连接书籍、互联网和流行文化，与你最喜欢的作家、书评创作者和大量的过度思考观点。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Prose Society》。
So like by age 11 or so, at least 70% have a phone. I'm Dr. Joy, and this is therapy for black girls. We spend our surviving middle school run getting into what's happening inside your kids' brain, the group chat, and their friendships, and what you can do about it. Your child is not doing this on purpose. That's the kind of perspective we've been pulling from the psychologists and psychiatrists who studied this for a living. Listen to Therapy for Black Girls on the IHart Radio app,
所以大约11岁左右，至少70%的人有手机。我是Joy博士，这是《黑人女孩的治疗》。我们在我们的“幸存初中”系列中深入探讨你孩子大脑中发生了什么、群聊和他们的友谊，以及你可以对此做些什么。你的孩子不是故意这样做的。这就是我们从以此为生的心理学家和精神科医生那里汲取的观点。在IHart Radio应用程序上收听《黑人女孩的治疗》，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. The countdown is on to the most talked about music festival on the planet. Let's go crazy. Our IHeart Radio Music Festival. Presented by Capital One, September 18th and 19th at T-Mobile Arena, Las Vegas. 15 artists, two nights, one stage. Listen on IHeart Radio stations across the country and stream it live on Disney Plus and Hulu. B-T-S
Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方。地球上最受关注的音乐节倒计时开始了。让我们疯狂起来。我们的IHeart Radio音乐节。由Capital One呈现，9月18日和19日在拉斯维加斯T-Mobile体育馆。15位艺术家，两个夜晚，一个舞台。在全国各地的IHeart Radio电台收听，并在Disney Plus和Hulu上直播。B-T-S
Bens and Boone Cardi B Sierra Gougou dolls Kenny Chesney Cessby Lamy Wilson Laceraphim
Major Laser Snoop Dog The Smashing Pumpkins Weezer Special Performance by Breakout star Stella Lefti And never seen before
Major Laser Snoop Dog The Smashing Pumpkins Weezer 特别表演：突破明星Stella Lefti 以及前所未见
artists collaborations You'll never see again One Wild weekend Are you ready? Buy your tickets now at AXS.com. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
艺术家合作 你再也看不到的 一场狂野的周末 你准备好了吗？现在在AXS.com购买你的门票。这是一个IHeart播客。保证人类。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。